two sets of cars 1 2 3 4 is 1 4 3 2 1
again aces one space and hearts black
and red they're in opposite orders I now
turn them over and we're going to
shuffle them and you decide which one to
shuffle but the shuffling means always
to take the top card and put it at the
bottom
that's shuffling okay that's one shuffle
and each time we shove it you tell me
which went which ones shuffle I'll
shuffle that one
okay so let's shuffle number of times
well what can we say oh let's use the
phrase numberphile shall we so
numberphile and you mb ER ph IL e so for
each of these letters you say welsh a
for the right one or the left one and
you can say you know numb3rs whatever
you like okay so brady you tell me which
one to shuffle them so left or right and
so and yeah you you mmm
may be yes sorry our p t HH alright i ll
okay so those two cards emerged to the
top as a result of your choice I didn't
choose this so I'm going to set them
aside
yeah two of them now we repeat
numberphile again and for each of those
letters we shuffle either of these and
you choose which ones shuffle for each
of those data so which one do you want
oh my god so okay M & u M R th I L II I
wasn't expecting this okay those two
cars emerged to top in fact this one
didn't move but this image the pop so I
put this aside now one last time
numberphile
and you choose which one to shuffle and
you baby
our th hill13.com
oh okay now if we were really lucky and
luck doesn't come except to the
deserving because number file is such a
magic phrase these two may be the same
number
you know number five means liking
numbers and these two numbers like each
other of course
two and two but that might have been
luck but if we really believe in that
magical number file these two might have
matched remember you chose which one to
shuffle yeah I didn't that's surely not
possible but what's really impossible
would be impossible is for the next to
the match and the surprised but
surprised last to ho so much so they all
match otherwise I mean it wasn't magic
so the trick that I have just shown you
is a classic trick which was described
for the first time as far as I know by
the late Martin Gardner called the last
cards match and I made a variation on
this and the variation is a little
slower than the original trick but it's
also mathematically more interesting so
I'd like to reveal the secret what we
had was two powers of cars you have one
two three four in one order and one two
three four or if you like four three two
one in the reverse order and these
should be thought of as like clocks okay
so a clock has you know one two three
four all the way to 12 and then it
starts all over again
so you are doing modular arithmetic here
also if you go one two three four and if
you want to go five you hear six years
seven here eight here and so we can keep
going okay you remember that our way of
shuffling was very special we took the
top card and then put it at the bottom
so you as you keep repeating this you
are cyclically
or cyclically depending on the side of
the Atlantic permuting those cards so
you go from here to here to here to here
and keep going
whereas in the other deck which had the
reverse order you go from
to here to here to here okay we had four
cars but let's generalize and explain a
little bit because this card trick works
with any number of cards in Jack let's
say that you have cards one two three
and so on
arranged in a cyclic fashion all the way
to M so let's say n minus 2 m minus 1
Amy's number total number of cars and I
choose that i M for a purpose on the
other side you have because in the
reverse order M M minus 1 M minus 2 and
the dr. you could keep going and then 3
2 1 you come back like that after again
so in our card trick n was four but in
general it works and one chef who does
this you start from one and goes to 2
and go to goes to 3 and here you go from
M to M minus 1 and minus 1 t minus 2 and
that kind of thing suppose that on the
left that is the red pile you made L
shuffles on the right you made our
suppose L is in left origin right well
the total number of shuffles that we
made was the number of letters in
numberphile n UMB
I 11 letters so we know that L plus R
was 11 for us so Ellen R are not
independent if you chose to share for
the red deck L times automatically you
are shuffling however whatever you else
you do the right deck R times but R
equals 11 minus L and if you choose to
shuffle the right deck that is the black
deck are times you cannot help stuff in
the left back that is a red red deck 11
minus R times so you have that
relationship so let's start shuffling
say that Keesha for the red deck L times
1 goes to so each time you increase by 1
2 goes 3 and if you keep going after L
suppose it takes a little bit of
thinking to convince ourselves you
arrived at not L but L plus 1 after L
shuffles on the right black deck after
one shafu you go from M to M minus 1 2
minus 1 M eyes
and if you keep going and that is
started as confusing at the end you
arrived at after our suppose M minus R
so after those shuffles because that
emerge on the top of each deck is L plus
1 and M minus are those two Casimir's we
used eleven but let's say that L plus R
was some number more generally which was
chosen to be some number which is
congrat minus 1 modulo M where m is the
number of cars in each deck so for us M
was 4 and for us 11 was chosen number
and given is minus 1 mod 4 by the way
where have you put yeah we'll have you
pulled that minus one more time and
we'll see why this minus 1 becomes
useful in a moment that's that's part of
the magic you have to do magic at some
point okay so let's see what L plus 1 is
compared with M minus R and we'll see
that they are actually the same thing
you see because L we see is equal to
look at this L plus R equals minus 1 or
concrete minus 1 so l equals minus 1
minus R let's not forget plus 1 so minus
1 plus 1 cancel and you are left with
only minus R so this is modulo M but
minus R can be written by modulus neck
again as M minus R that's the same thing
with you am doing it like that ok and so
what we see is that module M L plus 1
the top of the red deck and M minus R
top of the black deck actually the same
so after those shuffles the same cars
emerge on the top you put them aside now
you have to start over again and then
the number of cars M changes but that's
where minus 1 becomes useful 11 that we
chose that number of letters in
numberphile has the beautiful property
that it is indeed congruent minus 1 mod
4 that's the initial number of cars in
each deck after I set out the top cars
together
you have now do the same thing mode
three but 11 is also minus 1 mod 3 and
next stage you have you have lost one
pair of cars you have to do more - but
amazingly 11 is also minus 1 mod 2 and
that is why this number magic number key
number 11 worked just as you descended
those different moduli the chamber they
are mod 4 more 3 mod 2 okay and that's
how I chose 11 oh if you want to do this
card trick in other with other
parameters for example with larger
number of cards and 10 and 12 and so
forth and so forth all you have to do is
to solve this what is called
simultaneous system of congruence --is
like somewhat a nice system of equations
about you are doing modular arithmetic
and there is a way of doing it's called
Chinese remainder theorem by the way the
standard way we teach and learn Chinese
remainder theorem has modulized
are coprime they should all be co-prime
but this is a tricky case so Chinese
remainder theorem because for example 2
& 4 & on co-prime but even there there
is a version of Chinese remainder
theorem that works so this kind of
congruence system Congress is always
solvable so you give me any M so use a
lot of note cards if you like but just
reverse the orders here and here and you
find some key number which is equivalent
11 but some X which is minus 1 mod M
also minus 1 mod M minus 1 minus 1 mod M
minus 1 so all the way down all those
moduli you should always be minus 1 you
should solve those simultaneous
equations for X and using that number of
resist this trick always works but it
could be a longer phrase and longer word
and but I'm sure it to be somewhat like
a number file which would be a special
significance to you
if you'd like to try your hand at some
of the mathematical card tricks you've
seen on numberphile but don't own a deck
of cards well you could try these
numberphile ones there's a link with
more information about them down in the
video description and if you'd like to
see more videos about playing cards well
we've got a playlist for that links are
on the screen and again down in the
description